Southern nevadans observing a number of
opportunities to honor our nation's
Fallen this Memorial Day eight news now
reporter Mary Jane beliesza shares more
ceremonies across the valley at the
Lakes and in Henderson
across Southern Nevada we honor and
remember those who have sacrificed their
lives for our freedom Memorial Day is
important for a lot of reasons because
for many years people are now starting
to forget those sacrifices of veterans
that have served in the West Valley the
American Legion Post 76 and city of Las
Vegas leaders gathered for a ceremony on
Lake Sahara Tim Smith is a Persian Gulf
War veteran who served 18 years in the
military my father served in World War
II and passed away in 2000.
I continue on his legacy by trying to
help veterans and help their families
because that's what we need to do that's
why I'm very encouraged by the Junior
ROTC programs here in the valley Dennis
Christensen a Vietnam veteran who served
in the U.S Navy says America would not
be what it is today without our fallen
soldiers it is very important to honor
all those that even think about the
freedom of this country and what it's
done for all of us I think it's a great
honor just to be an American and I'm
proud to be in America
[Music]
at Cornerstone Park in Henderson Flags
remind the community of the bravery and
heroism of those who served Henderson
mayor Michelle Romero says this is a
tribute to not only our fallen soldiers
in Nevada but all over the country the
veterans community is a family the
military is a family and they look out
for one another and it's important to
make sure that they feel that familial
welcome here in Henderson